Hello world.
It's Saroj and welcome to intro to deep
learning and this first episode will
predict an animal's body weight
given only the weight of its brain.
This course will be four months long
and it'll all be released on my channel.
I'll have a live session every
Wednesday at 10:00 AM pst.
That explains every week's topic in depth
and I'm collaborating with you Udacity
to offer a nanodegree to those that
successfully complete this course.
This course is for anyone who wants to
learn how to harness the incredible power
of neural networks and become
a deep learning engineer.
You don't have to be an experienced
developer or a mathematician.
The only prerequisite for this course is
knowing quantum mechanics. Just kidding.
Only basic python syntax.
We'll learn what we need to along
the way by building an AI that can do
everything from predicting
the price of Tesla stock,
the painting surrealists masterpieces.
Traditionally programming has been about
defining every single step for program
to reach an outcome,
but machine learning flips that approach.
With machine learning,
we defined the outcome and the
program learns the steps to get there.
So if I want it to build an APP that
can recognize California license plates
instead of writing out coach,
you recognize the hundreds of
different features of a license plate,
like the shape of certain letters
and the colors. We just say,
here are some examples of
a California license plate.
Learn the steps you need so
that you can recognize it.
Or if I wanted to make a Bot that can
beat Super Mario instead of writing code
for every possible scenario,
like jump.
If you see a coupon and
it's running towards you,
we'd say the goal is to get to
the end point without dying.
Learn the steps to get there and sometimes
we don't even have an idea of what
steps could possibly be.
Like if we're a bank and we suspect
there's some kind of fraudulent activity
happening,
but we're not sure exactly how to detect
that or even know what to look for,
we can say,
here's a log of all user activity.
Find the users that are unlike the rest
and it will learn the steps to detect
the anomalies by itself. Machine learning
is already everywhere on the Internet.
Every major service uses it in some way.
In fact,
youtube using it right now to decide
which other videos you might like.
As you watch this and it's use
as will only grow over time.
It will be embedded in all of
our internet connected devices.
Everything from fridges, two
cars, two personal assistants,
we learning and adapting to our needs.
And you know that rule that says you need
10,000 hours to master any skill? Well,
we'll just be able to offload
that training time to our
machines and it'll give
us superpowers instantly. Anyone will
be able to compose a symphony. Alexa,
I feel melancholy. Make me a piano
piece for this and how to be to it.
Anyone will be able to direct the
movie. Okay Google, recreate star wars,
but put me in it.
I dockerize most of my code now.
Damn right. With machine
learning, if you can dream it,
it can exist and the field is currently
advancing very fast as researchers build
on each other's work. Ah, my
neural nets sucks. Go deeper. Wow.
I just achieved state of the art.
There are a lot of machine learning models
out there and one of them is called a
neural network.
When we use a neural network that's not
just one or two but layers deep to make
a prediction,
we call that deep learning.
It's a subset of machine learning that
has outperformed almost every other type
of model almost every time
on a huge range of tasks.
We'll dive into deep
learning more next episode,
but this video will just focus
on machine learning in general.
We usually class learning
into three different styles.
The first style is called supervised
learning. It's where we give a model,
a labeled Dataset like car pictures,
so it gets feedback on what's
correct and what's not.
It just had to learn the mapping between
the labels and that data and then it
can fall some given task like
classifying the type of car and an image.
It's all relatively straightforward and
we've gotten incredible results from it.
The second learning style is
called unsupervised learning.
This is when we give a model
a dataset without labels.
It gets no feedback on
what's correct or not.
It has to learn by itself
what the structure of the
data is to solve some given
task. This is harder to
do, but more convenient.
Since not everyone has a perfectly
labeled dataset sitting around.
Most data is unlabeled,
it's messy and complex,
and the third type is
reinforcement learning.
This is where it model isn't
given feedback right off the bat.
It only gets it if it achieves its goal.
So if we're trying to create
a reinforcement learning
Bot that can learn to beat
humans at chess, it would only
receive feedback if it won the game.
Whereas in the supervisor approach,
we get feedback every move and
in the unsupervised approach,
we'd never get feedback even if it won,
unlike the other two learning styles.
Reinforcement learning is linked to the
idea of interacting with an environment
through trial and error.
So I've got a data set of measurements
of different animals and we want to
predict an animal's body
weight given its brain weight.
Since our data is labeled.
This will be a supervisor approach and
the type of machine learning task will
perform is called regression will write
out a 10 line python script to do this
and I'll explain things as we go.
We'll start off by importing
our three dependencies.
The first one is pandas which
will let us read our Dataset.
The second one is psychic learn,
which is the machine learning library
we're using for this example and the third
is map taught live which will let
us visualize our model and data.
Now that we've imported our dependencies,
we can read our dataset using pandas.
We'll use the read FWF function to
read our animal data, set a table,
a fixed with formatted lines into a pen
as data frame object which is a two d
data structure of rows and columns are
dataset contains the average brain and
body weight for a number
of animal species.
Once our data is in our
data frame variables,
we can easily parse and read both
measurements into two separate variables.
We'll store our brain measurements and
the x value is variable and the body
measurements in the y value is variable.
So if we were to plot this data
right now on a standard two d graph,
it would look like this. And our goal
is that given a new animals bodyweight,
we'll be able to predict what it's brain
sizes. So how are we going to do that?
Yeah. Uh Huh. You know what it
is independent, independent,
independent and depend.
What data's got the values for
the brain and the body weight.
And I'm wondering what to
use to find that they relate.
Linear regrets helps
find the relationship.
We're gunna measure it and find the
only line of best fit the equation.
Y equals Mx. Plus B is all we need
is the y intercept and m measures.
House deed plotted on the graph.
Let's predict the body with the brain.
Low Air ops, champagne. Well
you suck.
It learns linear model object
to initialize our linear
regression and store it
in the body regression variable.
Then we can fit our model on our x,
y value pairs. Now that we have the
line of best fit, we can plot our x,
y value pairs on a map,
plot lives scatterplot, Ben,
plot our regression line by saying
for every x value we have predict the
associated why value and draw a line
that intersects all those points,
we can then display it
using the show function.
Let's go ahead and compile
this code in terminal.
Our scatter plot will appear with
all our data points mapped out.
The x axis represents brain weights
and the y axis represents body weights.
Our regression line seems to fit most of
the data pretty well and there seems to
be a very strong correlation here between
brainwave and bodyweight and as we
move along the line given any brainwave,
we can also predict the associated
bodyweight. So to break it down,
while traditional programming is about
defining the steps to reach an outcome,
machine learning is about defining the
outcome and our program will learn the
steps to get there. There are three
different learning styles, supervised,
unsupervised and reinforcement
learning and linear regression models.
The relationship between an independent
and dependent variable to create the
line of best fit,
which we can then use to make predictions.
The winter of last week's coding
challenge is Mick Fan Holt.
He modified the game world to be more
complex and his cue learning Bob was much
more efficient and reaching the goal.
Then my demo bought wizard of the week
and the runner up is Michelle Batu.
He generated maps using
cellular automaton.
The challenge for this video is to use
psychic learn to create a regression line
for a different dataset that all provide
and print out the error between your
prediction and the actual value.
Details are in the read me posts or
get help link in the comments and I'll
announce the winner in one week.
Please hit that subscribe button and
for now I've got to feel the learn,
so thanks for watching.